so this lecture is the second lecture on
the limitations and extensions of pins
um so we talked a lot about some of the
some of the limitations and extensions
last lecture and so this is going to
continue that
discussion so let's just recap um a
couple of things from the last lecture
and uh this is the key slide showing you
kind of the main advantages and Main
limitations
of at least standard physics informal
networks
um and uh we're focusing on these two
lectures on these limitations and so I
just I described these last lecture the
big kind of three limitations that uh we
typically see is that pins oftenly
computation expensive to train um
especially when you only want to solve
the kind of forward simulation task with
s with with
pins um they can also be very hard to
optimize it's not obvious or trivial
whether the uh gradient is sent or
whatever whatever optimization algorithm
you're using will converge to the kind
of ma Global Minima of the loss
function and often that's not the
case um and couple to that is is can be
very difficult to scale pins to more
complex kind of maybe multif physics or
multiscale uh
problems and so we talked a lot last
lecture about uh the first one the how
do we improve the computational cost of
pins can we speed up uh how they train
or perhaps whether they can learn across
across problem so they don't have to be
retrained for each
solution um and the whole point of these
two lectures is to tell you that yes
these limitations exist but there are
pins by now is a massive research build
and there are so many extensions that
try and address these
limitations so what were the ways we
discussed kind of speed up physics
informal networks um one of the main
ways that I described to you was a very
simple idea and it's just to condition
the pin on additional inputs of the
simulation that you're trying to carry
out so I call them I call these
condition pins and for example we looked
at simulating um seismic waves through
the Earth and if you just trained a
stand a pin on this on this simulation
here you would have to retrain it for
every Source location that you use so
each new initial condition of the
simulation so what condition pin does
instead is is it adds those The Source
locations the X and Y location of the
source uh to the to the as an input to
the network and then we train over many
possible earthquake Source locations um
when we're training the pin and so this
trains a surrogate model which once
trained can generalize across the source
location at least um in the rate in the
training distribution that you trained
it trained it over
um we also talked about uh these things
called I call discretized pins and
so the fundamental difference with disc
discretized pins is we instead of using
the neural network to directly
approximate uh the the solution to the
differential
equation and what what I mean by that is
the noral network represents or directly
approximates the function itself now
instead we say that the the network
outputs an estimation of the solution
but only on a grid of points so we we go
back to estimating a discretized
solution now that seems like a
limitation but it that has advantages
and the main one is that you can then
start to use kind of different Neal
Network architectures things like
convolutional networks that maybe help
represent or learn kind of spatial
correlations between the inputs and the
outputs of the of the of the network
um so how do we train these networks
well we can't get derivatives of the
output with respective coordinates
anymore because the coordinates are not
input to the network uh they're implicit
in the in the kind of output um mesh of
the of the network
itself so instead we we use finite
differences taking differences between
each mesh points to get our derivatives
with respect to x x and t or whatever
the
coordinates and I also explain to you
that we can condition these just like we
can condition p
um on for example initial conditions of
the P so when we're solving the burgers
equation here for example we can add the
initial flow velocity which in this case
is a sign sign wave at time equals T and
maybe even the viscosity parameter of
the underline differential equation as
well and in the same way this network
will train and learn a Sate model which
will be very fast once it's once it's
trained and and here's an example Le
paper that implemented these discretized
pins and they showed uh they trained
them to solve dar's D Dy flow so the
flow through a porest
media and what I find kind of remarkable
or really really great about these
methods is that they're fully
unsupervised so so you don't need any
training data to train the surrogate
model all you need to know is what the
underlying differential equation it is
it needs to satisfy it and and lots of
examples of inputs like initial
conditions of the of the system and it
will learn to simulate just just by just
through this learning process and
minimizing our PD
residual so that's the kind of big
that's the kind of big advantage of
these of these
methods okay so I already explained this
we we're talking about the limitations
of pins and um last lecture I covered
the computational cost so this lecture
is all about uh thinking about the other
two limitations so how can we improve
the convergence of pinss um to to
improve the optimizer or navigate The
Lost landscape uh
better and then how do we really scale
pins to problems that we care about you
know solving like big multiscale multif
physics simulations um and these two are
very challenging and and still
definitely open areas of
research
um so originally I said last lecture Sid
Sid would take over halfway in this
lecture we decided he he'll just come
and give his first uh lecture uh on
Friday on on on the theory behind pins
and so that will be the last the last
lecture on pins and then Sid is going to
carry on teaching for a large block of
lectures and he'll be talking um about
operator learning and there'll be a lot
of lectures on that
topic so I'll come back after this
lecture um here when we start talking
about differentiable physics and hybrid
workflows and then I'll take I'll take
the lectures till the end of the
course as well as our guest
lectures okay so let's talk about this
second limitation the poor convergence
of of physics in form noral
networks so this is a slide that I
showed last lecture when I was giving
you the high level description of these
of these
limitations and let me just tell you
what is happening here again so what
what I did in this experiment was train
a PIN to solve again uh the wave
equation so this is
simulating a a seismic uh wave starting
at a very a point source essentially and
exploding
outwards and um the pin after training
is able to model the solution which is
good but what's interesting is if you
look at the um convergence curve or the
the L1 test
loss uh as a function of the training
step of the network and and what I
showed you is that the pin exhibits this
thrashing
Behavior where um only after maybe
halfway through training does the pin
actually start to converge to the
solution and if I plot the pin solution
at training step 20,000 so uh you know
somewhere around here you can see that
uh the pin has only learned the initial
condition and it hasn't and it's put Zer
essentially everywhere else in the in
the
solution so can anyone remember why this
might be the case what why did we decide
this this was this was
happening yeah the
back yeah yeah exactly so the underlying
wave equation here uh a trivial solution
is the U equals zero everywhere um and
so this whole um part of the of the
domain you know from T equals 0.01 to
all the way to the end of the domain is
uh is satisfying that pdu residual term
in the loss
function um just just after the initial
condition the residual loss is probably
quite high but on balance across the
whole domain it's it's tried to minimize
it to probably a local minimum in in the
loss so what we have here is a natural
competition between trying to satisfy
the boundary condition and then trying
to satisfy the PD PD loss and it is
often the case that it's there's a
trivial solution that much easier to
satisfy in the PD loss but doesn't
satisfy the boundary conditions and
there's this kind of communication that
needs to happen between the two two loss
terms um so this is just reiterating
that point uh again we have our boundary
loss in our phys in our in our loss
function and we have our physics loss
here and a key way that we can kind of
control the balance between those terms
um is by is through these Lambda values
so these are kind of for a standard pin
these are just Scala
uh positive numbers that we usually
choose by hand so it comes down to human
experimentation like scanning across
these parameters to see which which pin
converge is
best
um and yeah if if Lambda is too small it
doesn't Lear a unique solution and if
Lambda is too large then it only
satisfies the batter conditions
so what I've got is um many actually
different approaches or ideas you can
think about to try and overcome these um
uh the the competition between the
Lambda terms or or maybe help help the
network learn through like to minimize
both those terms at the same
time so the first kind of idea is is is
is called hard boundary conditions or
hard initial on boundary
conditions so what is this do this says
well at the moment if you look in the in
the loss function the initial conditions
are satisfied in a soft soft
way that means that um the N the final
Network that we trained might not
perfectly satisfy the boundary
conditions this the boundary loss might
still be greater than zero for example
and typically that is the case so but is
there a way that we can reframe the
optimization problems or or the the way
that we Define the pin so that the
boundary conditions are always exactly
satisfied so we don't even have to worry
about matching the boundary conditions
in in the
network so it turns out there are there
are there is a way to do this or there
are many ways to do this um and kind of
one of the key ideas is to use the newal
network as part of a solution anets so
do you do do people know what I mean by
an
anets some some some yes and some no
okay so what I mean here is that
instead of saying that the noral network
directly approximates the solution so
noral Network approximates you of x and
t what we now say is that the solution
or the noral network is part of a
mathematical anet so this is just some
mathematical function which is our like
guess of what the solution should
be and so the nor network is now part of
a mathematical ANS and that entire anets
approximates the solution rather than
the noral network directly
and what we do is we design by hand uh
usually that that mathematical anets so
that it already satisfies the initial
boundary conditions without us having to
train the
network so let's just take this example
of the burgers equation um and we had
importantly these two um in initial
conditions or boundary conditions so we
said that time equals zero the starting
uh uh speed of the of the fluid should
be a signal audal
curve and then on the edges of the
domain the the flow should be zero so
this is modeling the flow through a
pipe um so if we if we just assume that
our solution is approximated by this
mathematical function uh and uh the
neural network is the only kind of
learnable or flexible function part of
that
function what what we're doing is we're
timesing the network by T minus one x +
One X - one and then we're subtracting
minus sin
pix so now just by choosing this answer
actually you can you can see very easily
that that it already satisfies these
initial and boundary conditions so you
can see that if for example um I plug in
we want this first condition you x
equals time time equals z should be this
sign function so here when T equals z
what happens to this whole term
here it's yeah it's zero right yeah it's
obvious so then U xal tal Z is exactly
sin pix so we don't have to use a
boundary boundary term here same with
these two constraints so uh you know if
I set x equals to minus one here uh that
zero is at this term but also sign xals
minus one is also zero and so that also
satisfies
this so the key point is that if we and
the difficult thing is to choose the
anest but if we can do it um then this
turns the whole problem from a
constrained optimization problem where
we have this boundary uh constraint to
an unconstrained optimization problem
where all we're doing is uh um
minimizing physics loss and we get rid
of this competition between these two
terms and does that makes sense has
anyone got any questions on on
that so so where might you not be able
to use this this kind of handwritten ANS
anyone see any limitations with
that yeah
y
yeah yeah yeah so if if your initial
conditions have some inequality or or
something like that yeah maybe
yeah so another another reason is uh the
here the boundary condition is very
simple think about solving a much more
complex PD for example
um I want to model the flow past like an
aircraft Wing or something and I have
boundary conditions over the wing uh
then I have to somehow write that as a
mathematical constraint inside of my
answer that's like am I going to
determine the distance to the wing so
that I can zero out the newal Network's
um value at that exactly the wings
location so there are there are ways
around it but um it can be more
challenging when the initial conditions
are more complex
[Music]
yeah so actually if I hear what you're
saying correctly there are approaches
where you can like um learn distances to
the boundary using another nural Network
and then use that trained pre-trained
Network to help you write these
answers so this is another
approach
yeah um okay so there's a couple of
things to not uh a nice kind of machine
learning interpretation of this is is
just to think of uh
this final kind of um evaluation of this
anat is just the final layer of the
neural network you know we're just
taking some output of some hidden State
and then we're timesing it by some value
and doing a subtraction sign like it's a
weird kind of activation or kind of
layer layer but nonetheless it's just an
extra computation on
top and um if you think of it that way
then it's really obvious that you can
still get gradients of this with respect
to the inputs which we need to evaluate
the the phys lost because we can just
use Auto diff to differentiate through
the whole the whole
anets um and what's also really neat now
is we don't need any training data at
all we don't need any examples of the of
the boundary conditions because they're
hard constraints and so the pin now
trains in a fully unsupervised
way and uh it turns like it this can
definitely help for for a lot of
problems um so this is a paper that uh
uh was solving the fluid flow I think so
I think this is the yeah incompressible
NV Stokes equations um through a pipe
but the pipe has a constrict is
constrained in the middle so it Narrows
in the middle and you get a speed a
speed speed up of the
flow um so this it turns out when they
were testing different pins um so this
is the TR the ground Tru solution when
they were testing different standard
pins they couldn't find any value of of
Lambda so when they were using both
terms and L function to converge onto
the solution um probably because there's
quite a big diff quite quite a big
competition between the boundary loss
and the physics
loss but when they use the hard
constraints here then they were actually
able to converge the pin so so this
definitely helped for this for this
particular
example okay so let's think about
another another approach to uh try and
help the alleviate the competition
between these two
um and one idea again quite a popular
idea is to now think about using
adaptive lambas so instead of me going
uh and by hand man manually trying to
scan for the right value of the Lambda
of Lambda to use why don't we try to
adapt them based on based on the
algorithm as or based on the pin as it's
training so what this paper suggested is
is that um we don't just have a single
Lambda value for each boundary term um
we actually have a single Lambda value
for every collocation point in every
training point that we train the pin
with so here when we're summing across
all of our uh boundary points and when
we're summing across all of our cocation
points we times each each term each
summed element in the Lost function by a
separate Lambda value so that's the
first idea to have more Lambda values to
weight each point by by itself the
second idea is to learn these Lambda
values as we're training the pin jointly
whilst we're training whilst we're
learning the Theta values the the
parameters of the
pin so how do how do they how do they
learn these well they do this uh kind of
two two level kind of
optimization where the uh you first
update the weights of the of the pin
just like normal when you just by
differentiating through the the loss
function but then you then take a set
where you update the Lambda values and
you do this by doing instead of gradient
Ascent on the loss function you do
gradient Ascent on the loss
function so why does that make sense why
would you do why would you update the
the Lambda values using gradient Ascent
well um just think about DL by D Lambda
here for the for the physics loss term
um it's very trivial to show that the
this gradient of the loss with respect
to Lambda is just the residual value
itself you can just see that but because
it's Lambda Times by the
residual so then why does this still why
does this make sense why should we
change the Lambda value by the residual
can anyone think of why that's a good
idea
yeah
yeah yeah exactly you've got it so what
this is doing is is saying okay where am
I L is remaining
High uh you know uh I should increase
the value of land or I should care more
about trying to minimize the residual at
that location so you can think of our a
residual um as a function across the
domain and we're picking out the points
where the residual is high and we're
trying to pull them down to zero and
putting more preference on
that so from a machine learning angle
you could kind of think of Lander as
like an attention mask it's like where
should I attend to in my optimization
landscape uh to try and minimize the
residual and uh so yeah this
paper uh implemented these so-called
self- adaptive pins uh for the hel heals
equation and other other problems too
and um it converges well this is the PIN
solution uh on on this fairly high
frequency
problem and what's interesting is you
can plot the the final Lambda values
after after the pin's trained and it's
kind of curious or interesting to trying
and interpret these LDA values what
seems to happen here is the PIN is
focusing on on the high amplitude
regions of the solution so it's really
trying to match these these peaks of the
of of the
Waves
okay now another idea going along this
kind of theme of asking well where is
the PD residual high in the domain as
we're training and can we can we target
that region
what we can do instead of instead of
waiting that region in the loss function
we could actually just add more
collocation points where the PD residual
is high this is another strategy to try
and focus attention on the on the
regions where there's where there's
error so you can just imagine um
normally when we're evaluating the the
physics loss we're summing we're summing
over all collocation points to get a
Scala value for the physics residual but
you can just you can just plot this uh
this here which is just the difference
uh before the summation and that that is
just a a value that you can plot across
the whole
domain and so you can just imagine say
we're training a PIN to fit some
solution and and it turns out that x
equals 05 like in the in the middle of
the domain the residual is really
high what we can then do is say okay
we're going to sample more corelocation
points at that close in the
middle and hope that that improves the
convergence because we're really
focusing on the PD
residual so this is the idea is to
adaptively sample these cocation points
as we're training by by treating this PD
residual as like a probability
distribution that we can sample
from
and so to do it we just as as we're
training we just evaluate the residual
and we we Define a distribution that is
uh uh exactly that residual divided by
some normalizing constant to make it a
probability distribution
so this kind of you could think of this
as like the pin analog of adaptive mesh
refinement like if we have a fixed
budget cocation points we're like
optimizing as we go through where we
want to put those cocation points to to
solve the
solution and uh indeed this this paper
they tested this um uh adaptive
refinement methods these are the kind of
bottom three techniques in the table
here across different PDS so the wave
equation uh Focus equation diffusion
um and it does seem that these methods
perform much better than kind of just
doing grid sampling for
example the other approaches you could
think of uh that or the other approaches
that they used in in this table are also
interesting to think about so instead of
just using grid sampling which in
general seems to be the the worst uh the
worst thing to choose they also they
also uh tested random random or quasi
random sampling so so these are all the
kind of uh strategies that they tested
and this is what the cocation points
look
like um I'm not sure but I think Sid
will go into more details about why we
should use quazi Rand R random sampling
in in his
lecture um any questions on this method
before I before I move
on yeah
soce the vector of
you were talking about uh the previous
technique so the Adaptive Landers okay
same yeah so these these are two
separate techniques the first is to
adaptively learn Landers the second is
to adaptively shift your predication
points I'm not sure you could do both at
the same time if if you're thinking
that because the Landers depend on where
where they are in space uh but I don't
know that could be an interesting
idea okay so we're going to move on to
limitation three uh which is scaling to
more complex
problems
um so this is a really important
question really is uh most of the kind
of applications of pins that I've showed
you so far are solving what I would
describe as toy or simplified problems
where you know we're solving the fluid
flow past a cylinder or we're doing um
wave simulation in a in a very
restricted
domain but what we care about really or
what we're shooting towards is designing
new simulation algorithms new inverse
algorithms that can cope with real world
problems like can we simulate
earthquakes across the whole state of
California or can we do a full Global
Climate
simulation and this is just a very valid
question is you know how do pins or or
more generally how do these scientific
machine learning techniques that we're
studying scale to these types of these
these types of
problems and um our traditional
algorithms often often really struggle
in these settings so you know as we add
more multiscale multiphysic
multiphysics uh
components as we had higher frequencies
when we start to think about real and
sparse and noisy data
and I showed you this example this
experiment last lecture um to to
describe this limitation and I'll just
recap it so what we what we're doing
here is we're training a pin on a very
very simple OD which is the U by the XIs
cos Omega X and the solution is just a
sign sign
wave and what we noted is that the pin
converges very quickly for a low
frequency solution but as soon as I
increase the the frequency of the
solution the the pin the standard pin
really starts to struggle and I had to
increase the number of layers and free
parameters in in the in the pin just to
be able to model the cycles of the
solution going from 320 parameters to
over 60,000 parameters in in the pin um
and not only that the the accuracy of
the final solution is much poorer in
terms of relative loss than than a than
than the pin in the low frequency
case so this is a big issue if we want
to scale pins to these kind of more
complex more complex
problems so why is this the case like
why why is the PIN struggling to solve
high frequency uh
problems so one of the reasons uh and
and it is a big reason is this kind of
so-called spectral bias of neural
networks so hands up who's heard of
spectral
bias okay maybe one or two yeah so this
is a general property of of noral
networks
um um even if we're just training a
noral
network a not a pin so just with a
supervis loss to match some data noral
networks tend to prioritize learning
lower frequency functions uh first or or
they take much longer to learn higher
frequency components in in their
training
data so this is an example that was this
is a paper that was investigating
spectral bias and and what they're doing
here is they're just training an oral
Network to fill
a multiscale function so this is not a
pin anymore this is just supervis loss
trying to fit trying to fit this
function and as you look as you see how
the neural network trains it starts to
fit these low frequency components of
the of the function first and then
eventually fits the high
frequencies and you can kind of see the
frequency content of the solution as a
function of of training interation
here um so this is actually one of the
reasons why early stop remember I was
talking in the Deep learning uh
introduction about early stopping being
a good regularization method it helps to
stop your network overfit your data you
know if maybe this low frequency trend
is actually is a good Trend if this data
is
noisy this is a reason why early
stopping can work
y
the so this is just um mean squared
error yeah so no regularization this is
just difference between blue line and
green line
yeah so that that's
it so what's really interesting is
there's a whole theory behind this that
I don't have time to go into uh but you
can use tools like Neal tangent kernel
Theory to actually analy under under
certain assumptions of the of the of the
Network's
architecture uh you can actually show
prove convergence rates of different
frequency components and you can you can
show that high frequencies converge much
much slower than lower frequencies
so this is great for maybe for when
we're talking about G like uh
overfitting or underfitting in uh
machine learning in general but when
we're training these noral networks to
to solve pdes this is not a good
situation we actually want to be able to
converge fast on these high frequency
components and on the low frequency
components uh especially if we want to
solve these multiscale uh
simulations so here's just another
example I showed you when when I was
describing pins this damped harmonic
oscillator problem and and the PIN for
the problem that I CH is converged very
nicely but what I didn't show you is if
I increase the frequency of the
oscillator or equivalently if I just
model the oscillator out to to longer
time
values uh the standard pin actually
really starts to struggle and it takes a
long time to fit the solution and this
is this is Rel related to that spectral
bias there's also some other factors
that are making this harder to converge
as well um or just the fact that it's a
bigger optimization problem you know I
need more collocation points to learn
higher frequencies so that uh you know
I'm sampling uh um enough points to
sample the frequency
well I need a larger or network I need
more parameters as I just showed you in
that previous slide and we have spectral
bias so this all of this all of these
factors compound and turn turn The
optimization problem into a
significantly harder optimization
problem
okay so we'll just take a short break
and then I'll I'll talk about ways that
we can overcome this and uh yeah let's
just take a short
break
so what I'm going to do now is talk
through again uh extensions of pins to
try and overcome the spectral bias or or
help them scale to high frequency
Solutions so the first idea is to use
something called uh forer features
um so what are foro features and why are
they a good idea so uh what foro
features are you can think of them as a
custom layer inside of our fully connect
fully connected Network so so everything
I've been showing so far we've just been
using for the most part just standard
fully connected MLPs uh as our Network
architecture and we haven't really
thought about changing the architecture
of the PIN to help it
converge so what for features do is they
say okay before before my fully
connected Network um what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take my input
coordinates and I'm going to transform
them before I put them into the into the
network and the specific transformation
that I'm going to use is uh uh I'm going
to use trigonometric Transformations so
I'm going to take my X so X here can
contain you know x y t however number of
Dimensions you have as as
input and I'm just going to take the
cosine of x and the S of x
um now X is a vector and and and I times
it by this this Matrix here which
essentially represents the the frequency
of the of the those S and cosine
transforms um so this Matrix has shape K
by D when D is the number of inputs and
K is the number of for features that
we're going to use so so we're
essentially just taking lots of sign and
cosine transforms uh with lots of
different frequencies and we're going to
form that into just one big hidden
hidden State before we put that into the
noral
network um typically we we sample these
frequencies these this uh uh Matrix here
uh just from a normal distribution so
and we we fix mu and the standard
deviation to to to sample from Whatever
frequency range we of interest that we
want to
Target
um so what does this do intuitively it's
well it's kind of hard to understand to
be to be honest um what it is doing is
putting or transforming the inputs into
some to to some frequency to some
functions that have a whole range of
frequencies before we do kind of a a
fully connected Network on top so if the
fully connected network doesn't learn
very much then we're already kind of uh
our kind of inductive prior here is that
the output function would already
already have lots of frequencies in it I
guess that's kind of the best
description that I can I can give you
um and uh what you can do though and
these these papers looked into these F
features in much more theoretical
details you can actually again under
certain assum assumptions of the network
show more much more favorable uh train
conversion rates of of higher
frequencies when using for example this
Neal tangent kernel Theory to to
investigate convergence
rates um so they showed they showed uh
in this in this paper here uh if I take
a multiscale problem so this is solving
the 1D passons equation but the solution
they CH they engineered the solution so
that it has two frequencies in the
solution one low frequency sine wave and
and a high frequency sine wave writing
on top of
it and uh you know a pin without without
uh just a standard fully connected
network uh really struggles to fit both
of these these uh uh frequencies in
facts it doesn't converge at all and and
it seems for this for this case these SP
features help and and help us converge
both on the high and the low frequency
components um but it it turns out that
there's no free lunch here but you can't
just model any possible frequency and
that the frequency range that the pin
likes to converge on when it has these
for features very strongly depends on
these uh new and standard deviation of
your of the F features of the input to
the network
um
so the problem then becomes trying to
figure out which uh which frequency
which which frequencies to include in
your for features to to best match the
solution that you want to try and uh try
and
solve does this make sense or any
questions on this yeah question in for
Allin adaptations yeah actually need to
know how solutions inorder to all this
right yeah
yeah and so uh and you're right you
actually pointed out the the main
limitation of these extensions and and
also the ones that are coming up by the
way
um and I don't know of a good way to get
around this uh I would also I would
argue that traditional numerical methods
also have this problem like if you're
doing F we have to design we you know we
design the mesh so that it fits the
solution that we think is g to occur um
and the the the traditional method to
solve that is to use like adaptive
method and and I guess those adaptive
landas or adaptive coration points is
like the pin analog of of that so so I
think what You' have to do in practice
is combine many of these extensions
together and that is what kind of a lot
of these latest papers do is that
they're using lots of extensions at the
same
time any any more
questions
okay so here's another approach to try
and overcome the kind of spectral bias
or or challenge of scaling pins to large
problems and that's to combine pins with
the main
decomposition so what's the overall idea
here well the the idea is to say okay
that Global optimization problem trying
to fit one noral network uh across all
of the collocation points is a really
hard and complex
problem what if we take a divide and
conquer approach where we try and turn
that big Global optimization into lots
of smaller perhaps coupled optimization
problems and just the hypothesis here is
that if we take a divide and conquer
approach then that those uh coupled
optimization problems are easier to
solve than a than the single Global
optimization
problem so what is the exact divide and
conquer approach that we would use well
this idea is to uh divide the modeling
domain so the whole solution domain into
many different
means and then instead of having a one
single Network that represents the
solution everywhere we place a separate
neural network in each subdomain of the
solution so for example here we would
have a neural network that learns the
solution in this red red region another
one in the yellow and another one in the
green
region okay
so kind of one of the first papers that
that proposed this idea was this uh was
extended pins
so so they did exactly this they they
said okay here's my solution domain I'm
going to have three new networks here
and each is going to tell me the
solution you know each is going to take
the coordinate as input and give me the
solution um as output but it's only
going to model it in in that subdomain
and not the whole
solution so then the question is how do
you train each of these networks and
what loss functions do you use to train
each of
them and uh so here is the loss function
for an individual subdomain so M here is
the is the number of the
subdomain and actually the Lost function
looks very similar to this the standard
pin we we keep we have the boundary loss
we have the physics loss um but the
important thing that we have to also
include is interface conditions so we
have to say the solution along the
interface should match across these
different
subs and that's the really important
extra term that ensures communication
between the solutions and Mak sure that
the solution globally as a whole uh
obeys the Glo kind of global boundary
conditions and and connects
properly so I mean this is a general
property of any domain decomposition
method for for solving differential
equations is they inherently have to
have some communication between the the
subdomains uh to be able to solve solve
the global problem and this is where
this is where it turns up in in these
extended
pins um
the big kind of issue with this is the
this interface condition making sure
that the solution matches across the
interfaces is not a hard constraint um
it's just softly constrained in this
loss function and is often not minimized
fully and you can really tell this when
you look at the difference between the
true solution here and the predicted
solution after we've trained all these
subdomain networks and what we have is
discreet jumps in the in the solution
and so this doesn't work if we expect
the solution or is not a not maybe not a
good representation if we expect the
solution to be continuous everywhere for
example on the flip side for some
problems where you do actually expect a
disc discontinuity in the solution or
maybe you have kind of uh multi physics
or different regimes in the
solution sometimes this idea of having a
separate network does help you um model
these discontinuities in the solution so
so there are some cases where this
works um yeah I just described this
limitation
so I'm going to describe now a different
approach which is the same idea so we're
using domain decomposition and having a
separate noral Network in each subdomain
when we're training the
pin uh but the difference here is that
we're not going to have uh disc we don't
want to have these discrete jumps in the
solution of the
interfaces and so this is some some work
that we did so we we we proposed finite
basis physics informal networks and so
how are they different to these extend
their
pins so as I said uh FB pins um they do
the same thing so they divide your your
um so now this is a 1D problem to make
it easier to understand they divide Your
solution domain into lots of subdomains
but the key difference is that we now
say that these subdomains are
overlapping rather than um
non-overlapping so you can see each
subdomain here has some overlap region
here and what we say is we have an or
networking each each subdomain and we
say that the final solution now is just
simply a summation a ma you know a
mathematical summation of each of the
neural
networks Times by some window function
that constrains the neural network to
that to that uh to that subdomain
only so this so these window functions
look like this uh and when we times the
network output by this window function
we're basically saying the Network's
output outside of its subdomain is going
to be zero because that's that's forced
by the window
function um so this is a very different
way to kind of frame the problem and
what we're doing now is
we're um
explicitly uh putting in the domain
decomposition in in an ANS of the
solution so we're mathematically kind of
writing in the The Domain decomposition
by way of summing and applying these
window
functions so if we train this FB pin and
I'm going to say how we train it in a
minute um
and we train it on this sinal audio
function and you look at the the outputs
of each of the subdomain networks Times
by the window functions you can see uh
what the solution that each subdomain
network is learning and in the overlap
region they're being summed together and
the summation is the is the full
solution
um so the difference between this and
the xpin approach is that by
mathematical construction just by saying
that the solution is this ANS with a
summation Times by these window
functions this this solution is
continuous everywhere there's no
discrete jumps in the solution because
this is just this whole thing is a is a
smooth mathematical function as long as
we choose smooth and continuously
differentiable window
functions um and therefore we can just
train this using the same loss function
as pins we don't need to have these
extra interface conditions in in the
loss function anymore we could just use
the standard pin loss function to train
to train all these
subdomain and in that way you can just
think of this anap here as just a custom
noral Network architecture that's that's
all it is is you could think of each
subdomain as like a a small noral
Network and they're all Sun together to
get the final Global solution and that's
just that whole thing is just some
custom architecture that we're
using any questions on on how we framed
the problem and and framed uh framed the
domain decomposition as a as an and of
the solution
yeah uh yes so you're getting back to
the point asked earlier about if we if
we how do we choose the domain DEC
composition yeah and so again this is
the limitation of this method and domain
domain decomposition in general is you
typically want to choose the dec
composition so that it fits the
solution um
so the standard the standard F pin
approach doesn't do this you have to
know something about the solution a
prior but you can choose the domaining
to fit it if you do so we're not limited
to having like fixed fixed uh size
subing here you can see each of these
are actually different
sizes and um what's cool and interesting
and we're actually researching at the
moment is whether we can learn these
window
functions so whether we can actually
learn the subdomain deal position and we
basically parameterize this window
function
we param so for example we say that the
the mean of the window and maybe the
width of the window are learnable
parameters and we we learn them inside
the pin
loss so uh here's an example of the fpin
training on this damp harmonic
oscillator
problem and the epin works much much
better than than the pin in this case
and um one of the tricks that I didn't
tell you about is
before we pass our coordinates into the
subdomain networks we actually normalize
them between minus one and one within
the subdomain region
itself and so what that does if you
think about modeling a very high
frequency
function um if we just have a subdomain
to learn one cycle of that one cycle of
that function when we normalizing the
subdomain we're basically stretching out
that function into a into a low
frequency function from the network
point of view so this is a way to around
the the spectral bias by normalizing the
inputs to to stretch out the frequency
components and this is another reason
why they're why they're training fast
and using that normalization is really
important what's your
question sort of how I would do it in
fin element I want
to look at it as some Bas fun I want
minimize all those yeah yeah yeah you
this is why we called it finite finite
basis pins because because the
inspiration was from finite element
methods where we say our solution it
it's very similar to this is where we
say our solution is a summation over
lots of local basis functions and that's
exactly how you interpret this you say
my network is now learning those that
basis function rather than the Basis
function being like typically a polom or
a tent function or whatever you want to
choose so I really like that
interpretation because then you're
starting to really bring like have a
unified understanding of like FM and how
FM related pins for example pins like a
standard pin is like fbm with one
element and a really big basis function
that's the way you think of it and
that's also interesting to think about
the computational speed because
FMS can be solved much quicker than pins
because they use very simple basis
functions if we have a polinomial then
we don't have to use gradient descent to
get the the weight the parameters of
that polinomial that we're fitting in
that we just use a linear
solve whereas here because we have a
nonlinear basis function we're relying
on gradient descent like optimization
algorithms to get those to fit those
basis functions so you can start to see
the playoffs here maybe this this thing
here is more expressive and the fbm is
less expressive perhaps like yeah and
depends what your solution is that you
want to
model uh the other cool thing apart from
the fact that it converges much better
than the pin is that it takes much less
flops to train so this is the you know
raw flops that it took to train the FB
pin so can anyone tell me based on this
slide why why not only does the FB pin
is more accurate but it takes many less
flops based on the numbers that I'm
showing in this in this
slide
yeah the subdomain is much
smaller um so the question I'm not
asking about whether it's easy to train
um I'm asking why it's far it's less
expensive to train so why why is there
why do we need less flops here so so I
haven't actually made this clear so so
these lines here have the same number of
training
steps so we we used like I don't know
however many 15,000 steps for for each
thing here but after 15,000 steps we've
only spent like 1.2 flops to train the
FB pin versus for for flops to train the
pin so so why why did we why did it take
less
flops what's flop uh floating Point
operation so this is a measure of how
much number crunching did we do to train
the pin so how many
operations
yeah so the architecture is not so the
pin is here is two H laters and 64
hidden units the FP pin has 15
subdomains so 15 subdomain networks but
each subdomain is much smaller so it's
one hidden layer in 32 hidden
units so I think you basically got the
answer and with f pins we can get away
with using much smaller subdomain size
Network sizes in each subdomain because
they have to learn a much simpler
function
um and that basically means that there's
a lot less computational drops required
to to train to train all those
subes it's actually
computationally training the FP pin is
equivalent to training a single Global
Network with this with the same number
of uh weights as each uh subdomain
network
has uh so that's another kind of cool
cool property of f
pins um so we can extend to multiple
Dimensions very simply by doing a domain
decomposition over High dimensional
spaces so this is what it would look
like in 2D very and I analogously um we
don't change the the ANS or the way that
we sum the solution
tool um so here's an example doing FB
pins in 3D or or 2D plus time and uh
what what the simulation we're trying to
do here is a multiscale wave equation
simulation so we're starting with three
different sources now and each Source
has a different frequency range so um
this simulation would be very
challenging to to converge a pin on and
that um
uh whereas the FP pin here does converge
fairly stably as as it
trains um and the code that we have now
is is fairly scalable so it's actually
running 30 by 30 by 30 uh subdomain so
27,000 newal networks at the same time
we're training uh but only only takes
two hours this is still slow slow
compared to FN but definitely faster
than training a global
pin um and about a million parameters
and very small subdomain Network work
sizes in each subdomain so one hidden
layer eight hidden units you think about
the basis functions we use for fbm we're
kind of approaching those
now one last slide on FB pins uh another
cool thing is that just by using the
domain decomposition you can actually
start doing parallel computation so you
can train them in a very highly parallel
way so one I one idea of implementing
this uh for example on multiple gpus if
you would push subdomain to a separate
GPU and feed all of its individual
points separately to each
GPU and you would compute all of the
outputs of the subdomains in parallel
then you would need this one
communication step where they share
their their their outputs in the
overlapping regions and then we show in
in our paper that you can then back
propagate and train the networks uh in
parallel without having to do any more
any more
computation so long story short they're
very paralyzable as well and so this is
another key kind of consideration is if
I want to scale to a bigger problem can
I put it on multiple gpus or or multi-
threaded uh cores for
example okay so um I've covered all
those big limitations the uh uh the
computational costs the poor convergence
and the scaling to more complex problems
uh what I haven't covered is all of the
other pin extensions and and like I
showed you before there are now hundreds
of pin extensions out there in it's a
really big research
field and this slide is just trying to
cover some of the some of the bigger Big
Ideas that I've missed or I haven't had
time to
cover and so there are there are many
more extensions so uh there are
extensions for example in the
differential equations or the classes of
differential equations that you can
solve with pins I've just been talking
about fairly simple partial differential
equations or Odes but you can solve much
more exotic equations like fractional
equations or stochastic pdes for
example we've only been using the strong
form of the underlying differential
equations in our loss function uh but
you can also use other forms like the
variational form and this uh this starts
to again make pins look more like finite
element
methods uh you can use mixed
formulations uh uh and and many other
many other
approaches another thing to do is to
incorporate certainty estimation when
you're training the pins so can can you
actually learn uh for example when we're
doing inverse problems with pins can we
learn the like distribution of possible
parameters given the observations that
we have when we trying to solve an
inverse problem rather than just guess a
single point value of what that that
parameter
is so there are basing pins there
there's gam pins Etc uh there are
there's a lot of innovation on the
architectures so for example using
adaptive activation functions using
these for features using sign activation
functions using Wave layers using lsms I
don't have time to go into the pr and
cons of all of these but there's a
lot and then there's also been a lot of
work on on the optimization side and and
instead of just using a standard maybe
Adam Optimizer that we use for most of
other machine learning tasks are there
more bespoke optimizers that are more
suitable for Pins um and some of these
look into ntk Theory to kind of
understand to design the optimizer and
you can do causal training strategies
and there's many many other
approaches also by now there's there's a
huge ecosystem in terms of the software
libraries of pins now so Nvidia have
this platform called modulus which it
allows you to uh uh write and train a
pin very quickly also incorporates many
other Simo algorithms as well there's
dpex de there's neuro differential
equations there's pythons there's
there's many other libraries as
well so in the last I have two more
examples that I'm going to show uh in in
this lecture the first is uh doing
basing pins so trying to incorporate
uncertainty estimation into the pin and
then the final one is to is to look at
wavelet layers as a different type of
architecture to to
use uh but if you're interested in this
I recommend this review paper or yeah
just reading around there's lots of
great material on pins out there
okay so let's talk about basy and pins
and this is this is a technique proposed
by this
paper um so what we want to do is we
want to frame this problem of solving
the differential equation as a
probabilistic task rather than just uh
learning a single solution so what do I
mean by that um what they what they the
the task that they imagine in this paper
is to
say that's have instead of exact
measurements of the solution and the
boundary values and maybe the the
forcing function in the PD so so this is
the ter the terms are different here but
it's the same setup so we this n here
describes the differential equation the
operator and we just apply the
differential equation operator to the
solution and get some forcing function
as the as the differential equation and
then B here determines the the boundary
operator and we get some boundary value
here so this is just a different way to
phrase phrase the problem
um so given noisy Val uh noisy values of
F and B so this is values of our
boundary and values of this uh forcing
function in the differential
equation and maybe some noisy values of
the solution
itself can we can we fit a neural
network to to model the solution but not
just a neural network can we fit a
basian neural network to the solution so
and so how is a Bas Network different
the difference is that instead of having
single value used for the weights we
assume that the weights uh are actually
drawn from some prior distribution
typically we assume that they're drawn
from a gan
distribution and the goal of uh the
learning problem now is to say can I
given all these noisy dat data points
can I infer what the posterior
distribution of the weights is so can I
actually yeah learn or or estimate the
probability of theta given the
data and we don't just want to get a
single value of theta we actually want
to get this whole distribution or if we
can't get the distribution we want a
sample from this distribution so we want
we want many possible samples of theta
given the
data so that's kind of the the
probabilistic setup of it and
uh you have to make some assumptions on
on uh uh on on the posterior or actually
on the on the likelihood here which is
the probability of the data given Theta
and on the on the prior which is the
probability of the the weights
so that you can sample from this thing
and the assumptions that they make is
that the the data likelihood this is the
probability of observing the data is
just uh we just assume that these data
points are drawn from some gum
distribution where our noral Network
models the mean of that
distribution um and then we assume the
prior on the weights are just gan gan
prior as I was describing
here so I appreciate that that's quite
heavy in terms of the the theory in the
model and and I'm not going to go into
it in detail but I'm trying to just give
you a a high level perspective on the on
the goal of this of this
model
um so then the question is once you've
got once you've got this model and this
model how do you how do you get how do
you estimate the posterior and one way
to do it and they show in the paper that
you can actually use standard ways of
sampling from the posterior so for
example hamiltonian monteal or more
generally um Markoff chain monteal
methods to sample from this
distribution and
uh uh so what they did in the paper is
they show this example of solving using
a a basing pin to solve the 1D posant
equation so this is the underline
differential equation and we're just
going to assume that the training data
that we have now are some noisy values
of the boundary values so this this is
the these are the boundary conditions
here that on the edges of the domain the
solution should equal these these Edge
values these These are the noisy bi
values here and then we also have some
noisy values of f here so these These
are noisy values of this forcing
function and you can see that we have uh
however however many 10 or so uh points
and these are essentially our
collocation points when we're training
the
pin so when you fit this phasing pin the
advantage of doing it now is that you
get this whole posterior distribution
and you can sample many possible
solutions that the the from that
posterior
distribution and so what you're what
you're seeing here is the the best guess
of or the mean guess of what the
solution is from that posterior
distribution and also what the mean
guess of the of the forcing function
is so I think this is quite a nice way
of um encapsulating or modeling the
uncertainty in in our training data
because we're not giving the pin the
full value of f we're only giving it a
finite number of samples of f it's quite
quite cool that this method can kind of
estimate uncertainty on F given that
finiteness of that training data and
then also give you the uncertainty on
the solution at the same
time so in in this paper they extend
this to doing inverse problems with pins
as well and it turns out you can also
get a distribution of possible um underl
parameters by training this basing pin
instead of just a single estimate of
what the underly parameter
is um I highly recommend you have a read
of this paper to to understand it in
more detail if you if you're
interested um the difference between the
the First Column and the second column
here is the second column just has more
noise on these observations and and you
can see that as we add more noise the
Bas in pin does give uh more uncertain
estimates of what the solution is which
is which is good to
see okay one one more one more example
and then uh we'll probably we'll finish
a little early
and is to is is on these custom nor
Network architectures for pin
and so what I'm going to describe is
some of the results from um actually one
of the M students in our in our lab and
so the star here was um a previous
student of of the deep learning and
scientific Computing lectur so this is
an example of one of the master students
that we we
supervised and what he was really
interested in was uh modeling the
elastic wave equation with with
pins so um all the examples of the wave
equation I've been shown before are the
acoustic wave equation uh elastic wave
equation is is modeling both
longitudinal and transverse wave so it's
a more complex version of the of the
wave equation and the solution in this
case you model the displacement in in
the X and the Y Direction so the
solution is actually a vector field
rather than a single Scala
value so what we've got set up here is
is a is a elastic wave propagating
through um a medium a constant or
homogeneous medium and you can just see
it propagates outwards so in the
circular
pattern um and so the observation that
we tried to do here was to say okay well
we know something about the solution
here like this well we were trying to
think how how can we characterize the
solution uh how can we write into the
network architecture that the solution
should be wavy in the kind of loose in
the loose
sense and the kind of and the idea was
to say well maybe we can represent the
solution as a summation over many
wavelets this so what is a wavelet this
is an example it's like a localized uh
pulse and there are many different
wavelet functions but this is this is
known as the rck wavelet this one that
I'm plotting
here and you can kind of see that you
could think of the solution as the
summation of these wavelets where there
where these wavelets are like slowly
propagating outwards and their
amplitudes are slowly changing over time
for example and maybe as they go through
different velocity regions the width of
the wavelet like stretches out stretches
in so and somehow it makes sense to
model this as like a summation over
these so you could also think of this as
a a physics informed kind of basis that
we're learning the solution so we kind
of instead of just learning this the um
the full solution we might just want to
learn the amplitude of these waves and
the the amplitude of these wavelets and
the width of these wavelets for
example
um so what he did was proposed this
architecture which he called the an
encoder decoder pin where what we did is
we had at the start we took the
coordinates and we passed them through
some fully connected Network here
instead of saying the output of that
fully connected network was a solution
we said actually that fully connected
Network that encoder part is predicting
the parameters of the of these wavelets
so so we set up the problem with say 100
wavelets or or 200 wavelets or more and
this the job of this network was just to
predict for each of those wavelets what
is the what is the location and the
width and the frequency of those of
those
wavelets so then we evaluate those
wavelets given given those parameters uh
we need the input coordinates to
evaluate the the values of those
wavelets the for those
coordinates and we sum them together to
get our
ANS now he tried training pins just with
this uh encoder and summation kind of uh
uh part and found that the convergence
wasn't as good and this was perhaps too
strong of a constraint just to say that
the solution is just the pure summation
of these
wavelets and the best model that he
found was actually
to add an extra fully connected Network
afterwards to to learn to sum these
wavelets in maybe a nonlinear way so or
maybe just do a non linear
combination um so what we're doing is
we're trying to add some Physics
constraints into the into the network we
keep still keep it flexible to learn
like the solution around
it and uh here's an example simulation
of of uh on the right here is just a
standard fully connected network uh pin
training on the elastic w equation and
then on the on the left is his proposed
model this encoder decoder waver
architecture and we're running this
architecture with 128 wavelets and some
small encoder decoder fully connected
networks either side of
it um and he got some this is just one
result from from his uh thesis but he
got some over over many different
tests it turned out that this
architecture was fairly convincingly
better than the PIN for for different
elastic wave equation
simulations and uh you can see in this
example so if you look at the difference
plot here this is the difference between
the the ground the finite difference
modeling in the pin
solution and the error here stays very
low for the for the encoder decoder pin
but for the pin it it grows much quicker
so we we get to something like 10% error
here whereas it's maybe 3%
here so just just another example of of
changing the network architecture to to
fit the fit the type of solution that we
want
model um so we we finished discussing
the limitations and extensions of pins
uh just to summarize standard pins for
sure have some big limitations their
computational cost their convergence
they for
scaling but the good side is that there
is a lot of extensions and a lot of
possible ways to overcome those
limitations uh depending on the problem
that you have and and this is very much
still an active field of research and
it's very exciting to see this field
develop so um yeah I hope you enjoyed
learning about pins and uh well you'll
have one more lecture about thetical
aspects on Friday so yeah thank you